I kind of scoff and laugh at vinyl heads
you know like it's a way to nuance
they're cool like oh man up Ivana
only there's filling in all types of
audio forms J Dilla when I'm one of my
heroes was in love with the cassette he
would often use a track just for
cassette hiss knowing that cassettes
were a thing of the past like this for
music he was making in in 2002 like way
into the CD age like he'd still felt
that hip-hop should be best experienced
the way that he experienced it which was
an amount of imperfections sort of a
loaf I sounding audio experience then I
respect that you know again I'm not one
of these people that has to make sure
that it's like AIFF form or this 3:20
bit perfect sound I'm open it like I
will rip something off YouTube if it
moves me a certain way